[Music]
hello hello hello this is Dan Hayes and
the doctor Greg Sadler here for wisdom
for life glad to be here so today we
have a very apt topic we are talking
about fear and anxiety on how to deal
with crises as well yeah
so one skin-on we are here doing a radio
show for practical philosophy yeah so
the idea behind this show is that
philosophy and ideas concepts
distinctions practices from it can be
useful for helping people to live a
better life and sometimes living a
better life which sounds very positive
is about how to deal with things that on
their face seem and quite often are
quite negative so you know we're kicking
around the idea about what topic to
focus on next after our first show and
we had something in mind and boom now
we're in a state of emergency so we
thought that we would change it up a bit
and talk about something quite topical
which is going to become I think
evergreen in the sense that we're always
going to be dealing with one crisis or
another so it's something good to tackle
right away I think yeah life is what
nothing but a series of tests put in
front of you and how you deal with them
is going to very strongly impact your
day to day happiness your calmness your
tranquility of mind yeah you know and we
should talk about the idea of crises in
in Greek crisis is sort of a deciding
point it's literally a decision right
and and so a lot of people get into
difficult situations like the one we're
in right now and what we'll talk about
that in just a moment will it plumb the
depths and and discuss why people are so
afraid
more so than at other times but you know
crises presents us with an opportunity
to choose differently to use them to
work upon ourselves and I know this this
probably sounds to a lot of listeners in
the actual crisis that we're in sort of
pie-in-the-sky pollyannish but but it's
not it's if you want to live a life
that's relatively free of fear and where
you orient yourself towards what what it
is that you actually want to do and you
know the relationships that you want to
have and all of those sorts of things
then you know using this this crisis
that we're in now caused by the
coronavirus but a lot of other things as
well is probably a good idea and every
time that we have a crisis it is a
opportunity to reflect upon how we've
done and see how we can move forward in
a better way and I have no doubt that we
will eventually whether this particular
crisis and hopefully we can take good
stock of the different things and the
decisions the crises that have happened
on and figure out better newer processes
and procedures that will help us in the
future just like all of our things that
we're trying to talk about here and
wisdom for life I'm talking about
practical philosophy
yeah and now let me ask you so we'll
make it a little bit more dialogical
taking stock of it right we might not
actually succeed in taking stock of it
national-level right no maybe maybe it
leads to some important political
changes and programs and realizations or
maybe it doesn't and but so what do you
mean by taking stocks it's something
more individual or something more social
but at a lower level than say the nation
as a whole I guess taking stock is at
any place where there is a decision to
be made and so obviously it is very
useful for an individual useful to take
stock each night and think about your
decisions that you did that day um even
you know you might want to do it more
often than even that but you know
whatever you have it's going to be
individuals that are put into places of
power that are making these decisions
and it's for them and each person that
is making these decisions to take stock
at that level and sometimes those things
affect only one person and sometimes
those things can affect billions okay so
you know Before we jump into talking
about the actual crisis that we're in
which may seem a little dismal I just
had a thought you know it strikes me so
we're talking about opportunities and a
lot of this show is about how to
implement and understand philosophical
practices that will over time make your
life better is what we call philosophies
a way of life and I was just thinking
that because people right now are
maintaining social distancing and also
to some degree self quarantine again
we're not exactly six feet away from
each other we're supposed to be here but
ideally you know we would be a little
bit further apart but there's gonna be a
lot of people who are staying in their
places they've stockpiled stuff they're
you know college classes for example are
now going online people are working from
home there's a whole other conversation
we had about the fact that we knew
people who people been told that they
couldn't work from home in the past and
now suddenly it's it's available for
them to do so as an option and even
mandated but during that time of being
stuck at home and avoiding say public
transport or other things doesn't that
strike you as a
a really great time to introduce new
habits new routines into one's life I
mean if you know that you're you don't
have to like immediately get out and hop
on the bus or do your morning commute or
something like that and you're gonna be
working from home and you know what the
hours for that are going to be maybe
it's the time you mentioned taking stock
of things at night you know yeah that
that practice that that's a good one but
maybe during the day as well well you
make a good point like a lot of us have
a certain morning routine that we are
set up and a lot of times we haven't
thought about it just like okay what are
the things I need to get done right at
this exact yeah and in order to get
myself to the place where you know the
boss isn't gonna yell me for not being
there on time or you know my students in
your case would be like where's
professor solar yeah I think a lot of
our morning routines are basically you
know like little crises get get the
stuff done in the morning so we can get
that get out of there and get you know
whatever we need to be and like you said
keep the boss from getting angry with us
for for not being where we're supposed
to be or not not you know doing the
thing that we're supposed to do or
looking busy at least that's another
show altogether how to look busy on and
on if you can there's there's many
different ways you can like start your
morning and maybe you're like okay how
do we have more call mine in the morning
instead of being in this racing setting
and I will okay I have a the opportunity
to you know experiment with different
ways of doing these things of of saying
okay can I give myself a little bit more
time on do I sit down and like I don't
know meditate or just like think about
what's going to happen that day and and
figure out if there's anything there
that will allow me to then have a better
day altogether yeah you know so
meditating is a is a good way to start
the morning and doing that sort of
morning preview one that's not let's say
all that internet-connected so you're
not like checking all the news and
seeing what what you know what Twitter
has to contribute but but rather just
sort of rehearsing in your mind okay got
I need to do this I need to do this I
think another thing that I've I've often
tried to introduce and sometimes succeed
for a while and a lot of people find
quite valuable is devoting a time you
know like maybe half an hour or an hour
of reading reading a particular text or
you know particular thinker particular
movement or something like that so that
could be quite good but you know let's
talk actually but why waking up in the
morning and immediately checking your
phone for the latest news during a
crisis might not be the the best way to
begin well I mean it there could be some
cases where it would be
oh yeah well you know there's pertinent
that you need to know but if it's like a
general kind of overall filling of
malaise about what is just going on
especially if you're talking about
political things and like you know you
wake up in the morning you just fill
yourself with the Oh dread or something
because someone that you don't like is
doing things that you don't like on
there's just going to color your entire
day what do that but I wanted to go back
because it's like we're talking about
waking up in the morning okay and a lot
of times it requires time and so you
need to even go back further you should
be starting your morning routine before
you go to bed and figure out what time
that you're going to go to bed in order
to make sure that you have the time in
order to do all these things that you
want to do to make sure that your day
and your life goes smooth or as smooth
as possible and this yeah that's true so
I mean we're another yeah that that's a
good thing to point out is you know
getting enough sleep which sounds very
easy to do but is often quite difficult
and practice turns out to be important
not just for physical health but also
for mental health and and being able to
follow through on things that we commit
to because we don't have an infinite
supply of what people like to call
willpower you know and the more
sleep-deprived we are the worse off we
are so we should talk about the the
reasons why people are staying up at
night waking up in
old sweats and worrying about maybe
whether they're not sick or not I think
that fits right into our topic here
which is your and specifically anxiety
yeah and and so you know right now we're
in the middle of a health crisis and it
you know there'll be other ones after
this we've had other health crises
before this so it's you know in talking
about this we're not doing something
that's just of the moment but could be
applicable to other cases as well but
what we're what we're in right now it
does seem to be quite bad and nobody
nobody really knows how how bad it's
going to be or whether it's all going to
blow over there's lots of people making
predictions but since we're stuck in a
strange pista melodical position where
we don't actually know how many people
are infected and we're now gathering
more and more information as time goes
on we we can't make accurate predictions
what we do know is that you know here in
where we're living in Milwaukee schools
are you know sending their students home
and saying switch to online which makes
sense a lot of workplaces are doing
similar things with working from home
it's pretty rough for people in the
restaurant industry because not a lot of
people are going there but they're being
told they need to come in to work and
same with the retail industry where
people are buying things out of stock
including toilet paper of all all things
and there's there's sort of a sense of I
won't call it generalized panic but
there is a there's a palpable fear in
the air I would say and then you know
just just a little earlier we had an
actual national state of emergency
declared and we see that it's around the
world there's lots of places that are
much worse off than us and there's some
that are doing quite a bit better so you
know we can talk about this as being a
major crisis and then it's not just a
health crisis it's also a financial
crisis we saw the stock market take a
huge tumble in part because supply
chains have been disrupted and
I mean what else should we say about
this it's so it's health its financial
and work and stress yeah yeah they're
you know and going back again to like
retail and restaurant workers a lot of
them are in quite a difficult situation
where they're they're being told they
have to show up for work and if they
don't show up for work they'll get in
trouble and if they call in sick they
only get so many times to do that and so
you know people are being told
contradictory things you know everybody
should be at home with two weeks or a
month worth of stockpiled stuff but you
know a lot of people don't have the
money to stockpile all these groceries
letter you know alone the time to go out
and compete with everybody else to get
these so it is a time I think in which
people are afraid and it's gonna lay
bare a lot of the inefficiencies in our
system he's gonna show where the cracks
are yeah that's quite true and and some
of the fears that people have are you
know less vital let's say I mean some
people are really afraid that they're
gonna get sick and they're going to die
if your immune compromised right now I
can quite understand being quite fearful
and then there's other people who have
fears but they're things like am I going
to get my tuition money back for this
class that now may or may not run and
you know what am i there's things that
are in between like am i homeless now
that the dorms are closed to students I
I'm talking a lot more about educational
stuff in part because that's that's what
I'm seeing from my vantage point maybe
you should say things about what you
think are particularly vital and fear
producing for people um
I guess from my vantage point I see more
of the the worry about especially your
hourly working yeah you're not a salary
position that you're going to have your
income stream dry up soon and then you
know what do you pay rent how do you pay
rent how do you put food on the table
you know there's there was a study
couple years ago saying that more than
half of Americans couldn't whether a
$500 unexpected expense which seems like
this is going to be definitely a $500
expense especially if you're losing
hours you're losing yeah aren't you the
the general day-to-day workings but I
wanted to talk about what is a a
rational fear and what's the rational
fear okay so yeah let's jump into the
discussion about fear there's you know
there's a lot of different theories of
emotion talking about what fear is
and one that you and I have in common is
taking the stoic perspective and I think
the Stoics they were right in saying
that what what fear is at its core and
they lumped a lot of things in there
under the rubric of fear Phobos in Greek
right the thing that we get phobia from
they thought that it's the sort of
perception of something bad that is not
yet present so we don't you know when we
have something that's bad that's present
we don't feel fear as such we feel pain
or we feel you know some sort of upset
but it's so-so fears is an apprehension
of something as being bad being harmful
being being damaging to us and it you
know it extends over and to other if you
understand it in this broad sense it
it's it's affiliated with other emotions
like repugnance or disgust right not
quite exactly the same thing but you
know within the same the same family and
so then the question is should we should
we never fear anything well even the
Stoics who are pretty you know and it
comes to emotions most of them they they
want to wean us away from they thought
there was a rational type of fear and
there are a lot of different subclasses
of it that they called caution you LA
baya and Greek and what's what's the
deciding factor whether it's actually
rational and not not rational in the
sense that we can rational
why is it to our smells right so like if
I'm if I'm will get away from crises for
a moment and talk about relationships if
I'm chronically afraid that my partner
is going to cheat on me that's not a
rational fear unless they are like you
know track record cheaters yeah which
case that might be a little rational
that you'd say well why are you with of
if if you want to you know are do you
want to be constantly worried about that
but you know there are some things where
it is rational to fear it not not just
in the sense of being able to provide a
rationalization for it but we can
provide a rational account for why this
thing is fearful if if I you know
there's a army outside your door yeah
good caution to you know prepare your
troops in order to fend off this army
who's gonna take something like right in
front of us while we're watching cars go
back and forth on Center Street here and
if if you were to walk me out in the
middle of the street and you got a
blindfold on me I should be scared I'm
gonna get hit right yes now if I'm not
there's something wrong get in the way
people drive good I was just going to
say there might be something wrong with
Milwaukee and they're driving in that
regard well I think you can pick any
city yeah so this reminds me of the
quote by Seneca a man who suffers before
it is necessary suffers more than is
necessary or in other words he who
suffers or he who worries suffers twice
and this is idea of you know you can be
cautioning you can take preparation but
if you are in the the state of mind of
the the facts the baddest of the fearful
state of mind or before things are
apparent that they actually will come to
pass then you are making it more
difficult for you to even deal with the
situation when there Rises right the
warrior the person who fears when it's
not really the right time for that fear
when it's not when it's not
rusev I mean we do have our fear
instinct which is is you know something
very basic to us the way most animals
have it because it helps to keep us
alive but there's so many things that we
we don't need to fear at this point in
time that we do and worrying and
sometimes even obsessing about and I
think during a crisis in part because
you know it's not just that we we have
the the fear of the things that the
crisis is composed of you know say the
loss of income or getting sick or what's
going to happen to our loved ones or
whether it's going to lead to a societal
you know breakdown in some respect
there's all of that stuff but then we
also have we're so tapped in with social
media and it's just the regular media
you know TV and stuff like that and we
think about every doctor's waiting room
you go in there's the TV that's on right
and it's always on some daytime TV show
we're talking heads are going back and
forth or a bunch of people are sitting
around in a circle talking about
something and nowadays they're all gonna
be talking about the corona brands so
that's not going to be particularly
helpful as well and you know all of that
falls within the range of what in
ancient philosophy they would call the
imaginary you know it's easy to imagine
that bad things are going to happen we
may have good reasons to think that they
are and if we do have good reasons we
don't have to imagine it anymore right
now we can say okay we project that it
will happen are we and now we can
actually start thinking about what what
responses can we have to it if if any so
this comes to kind of the idea of like
what are we going to be doing in the
crisis and so yeah is a major the first
thing is to get the most accurate
information that you can and then only
then should you make a plan of action
based on that information
ideally yeah yeah I mean it may be
difficult in some places to get accurate
information but here here in America we
all have access to the Internet so
there's certain basic
you might call them almost like
community property though that we have
that we can easily access and we should
avoid right yeah but a couple that are
definitely very useful at the moment
there's Johns Hopkins oh yeah
a university and they have a website up
at coronavirus dot JHU edu has a a
wealth of information as well as a world
map of where the current cases are on
sid rap which is the center the centers
for infectious disease and policy out of
the University of Minnesota has a
another also wealth of information over
at WWE trap that's
CID RA pee-eww um n dot edu and then
also we know we're here in Milwaukee and
Milwaukee health department has also put
out a page they put out a number of
documents that were presented to local
businesses in order to help at least
give guidelines and you can find that
stuff at city dot Milwaukee gov slash
coronavirus you know and and something
that just came to mind so we've got
really good reliable information sources
right and then we have a whole bunch of
other ones that are more sketchy all the
way to the to the spectrum of
essentially sensationalistic you know
looking for clicks to make money and you
know what we find in the distinction
there is the the good sites aren't going
to say oh everything's great you know
everything's wonderful they're gonna say
well we have a real crisis on our hands
and here's what you ought to do and they
do tell you not to overreact and then
you've got the sites that are like you
know the sky is falling and and and by
our silver that wolves yeah well and and
and you know by the silver and get the
toilet paper right now you know I mean
it's it's there's a bit of a digression
but if you think about the fact that
that toilet paper has become sort of
like the prized item almost like people
think it's going to be the currency well
it's whiter civilization
collapses yeah I mean it's not that good
because you get it wet and you know I
mean thick paper towels would be better
but not very durable yeah yeah it's not
very yeah you're right so that maybe
makes it even more rare over time yeah I
mean who would have thought that we
would wind up in a situation where
somehow that is instead of gold or you
know I don't know
bullets the way you see in
post-apocalyptic scenarios or gasoline
or something like that that that toilet
paper would become the prize making
coronaviruses the harbinger of bidets
and the united states well if you
I've seen people talking about that and
buying them and yeah I could lead to a
societal shift well so let's go back to
talking about fear I mean yeah and
rational fear right in let's think about
the toilet paper thing some people are
going out and and actually some
businesses have now instituted rationing
yeah limits on you can only buy so many
cases of it and there's they had a case
that I saw on Twitter of somebody going
into a Wegmans buying their the quota
mm-hm and then coming back in in a
disguise and getting caught and so you
know when that sort of thing happens
that tells you there's there's something
psychological going on right and the
fear that's that's driving that because
I don't there there are youth I think
maybe it was it you mentioned that
somebody was buying up toilet paper to
sell it yes profiteering yeah okay so
that's greed but I think a lot of people
are buying it on the basis of fear and
we won't go into like what the fear
actually is too much because we don't
want to get scatological here but a nice
word choice but I think some the fear is
redoubled because if if I know that
you're gonna go and buy up all the
toilet paper available because of your
fear then I have to fear that your fear
is gonna render me toilet paper less and
then I need to go and buy it myself so
so it's almost like a feedback loop
where fear builds off of the perception
of other fear and if we think about this
in
in philosophical terms what we have
there is my perception of you perceiving
something as bad whether it really is or
not and your reaction to it produces
that same thing in me it's almost it's
similar to what we call in philosophy of
emotion emotional contagion mmm where
but but it's not quite the same because
this is also based on a semi-rational
projection of what you're going to do
and then a reaction to that and so
that's the situation that we're in and
we could see hoarding with medicine well
I mean think about the what's going on
with hand wipes oh and hand sanitizers I
had to make my own last week because I
couldn't find any yeah
stores are some of them are engaging in
price gouging you know so you know it
feels like there's a lot of anxiety
going on and response to this thing yeah
there is and you know we can so what do
we have to say about this from a
philosophical perspective part of it is
this isn't serving anybody it's not
making anything better we're and we're
not here saying hey if you feel fear
stuff it down tough it out don't don't
feel it or anything like that but you
know what we'd want to be able to do is
examine what are we afraid of and why
are we this afraid and does it does it
serve us to be this afraid feeling fear
sucks
it's not it's not a fun feeling are you
doing it automatically or are you doing
it after you've examined why you're
doing it yeah and a not just examined it
with like a hasty check the boxes kind
of thing but actually like you know sat
down and thought about does this make
sense to be afraid like if I find out
that the guy who I sat next to on the
bus who was coughing into my face tested
positive for coronavirus it's rational
to be afraid that I have control devices
right it's not irrational for me to
think I'm automatically going to die
or I you know I won't be able to get any
medical treatment
those aren't those aren't you know sort
of the automatic places that we ought to
go but a lot of people will go there all
right and then bring up a another quote
this one from Marcus Aurelius from the
meditations it is if you are distressed
by anything external the pain is not due
to the thing itself but to your estimate
of it and this you have the power to
revoke at any moment yeah so what do you
take that to mean here in this situation
in this situation like we have a we can
have a rational cautious fear or with
however you want to call that about the
situation at hand and there is a
situation that is it's very rational be
cautious about yeah but on to to give
into that fear to UM be anxious to have
those those negative emotions be the
things that are driving your decisions
without any sort of examination results
in you just going along with flow your
now that the your slave of your passions
and not yeah the other way around
and that gets to the the practice that
we're going to discuss towards the end
of the show
wretches is like taking a pause and then
examining things so we'll put that off
for just a little bit but you know so
you're you know when we're talking about
taking precautions that can be done in
in rational and irrational ways as well
right hoarding is you know you could say
that hoarding is a rational behavior but
it's not truly rational it's it's
essentially fear or greed driven mm-hmm
or perhaps even Envy driven you know the
other guy across the way he's got you
know all this stuff piled up I better do
it too and if that's what's driving it
that's that's not very rational it leads
people to make foolish decisions and
often unjust decisions too I think one
of the things that we're not you know we
don't talk about that much
comes to these sort of crises but is
worth reflecting on is if we allow
ourselves to be prey to fear then we're
probably not going to live up to the
ethical principles that we normally in
in a non crisis situation claim to to
you know value and to to make make
central to the kinds of people that we
are but we're really being tested when
we're thrown in to these these sorts of
crises that's when we can see whether
we're going to treat our neighbors
justly or not so it kind of makes me
think of like the prepper community how
so so on they they have already
stockpiles so they're not going out and
and just tearing out everything from the
grocery stores there's that and you know
if you're just going there and you're
you in a very selfish way that you're
not thinking about yeah what is just for
your neighbor but at least for the
prepper on he's he's thought of this
ahead of time and so he's not
contributing to the mad rush yeah on and
the unthinking on hoarding there so yeah
if they are then they were a bad prepper
right right right yeah so there was
something from doom that you felt was
well appropriate but yeah I thought if
we're gonna talk about fear now not
everybody and as red dune but it is a
very popular science fiction novel and
justly so and there's a brand new film
coming in as well oh is there yeah yeah
so you know there's this passage very
early on and I think a lot of people
have seen seeing this in different
places and Paul Atreides is repeating
this litany against fear to himself
that's actually quite philosophical
right and it runs I'll just read it it
says I must not fear fear is the mind
killer fear is the little death that
brings total obliteration I will face my
fear I will permit it to pass over me
and through me and when it has gone past
I will turn the inner eye to see its
path where the fear is gone there will
be nothing only
I will remain and so you know this is
this is an example of a philosophical
practice only it's in a science fiction
universe right right
and it's actually you know we should we
should talk about this and cuz this is
actually a quite good one it's fiction
and science fiction doesn't mean that it
doesn't have valued really applicable
value within our real world yeah
so this notion of fear is the mind
killer what is it what does that mean
it's the thing that makes you on is
killing the rationality to one thing
it's also potentially makes you freeze
up and not do the things that are
necessary when they arise yeah that's
true you know we often talk about the
flight-or-fight response but it's
actually nowadays talked about in terms
of fight flight or freeze response and I
think we could actually add a third or
fourth one because that's the third moon
to it and we could say flight fight what
did I just say freeze freeze or
oscillate between things sort of dither
and not not get anything done which I
suppose is its own weird way of freezing
but it's like a freezing in motion mmm
you know and and none of those are none
of those by themselves are necessarily
productive there are some situations
where we do need to flee you know right
you know what in self-defense a good
instructor will not say Oh somebody's
got a knife yeah punch him in the face
or something like that they'll say try
to get out of there as quick as you can
that that makes sense
fight sometimes you have to do that and
freezing sometimes could even be the
thing to do I like taking pause was
being done instead of dithering that
could be a good thing but yeah so so the
mind killer that and that's a good way
to call it and then what does it mean to
allow fear to pass over you and through
you and then let it go on so that
there's nothing except you so this is
that mean this is kind of a preview of
coming to events where this is
part of our practice for the day which
is to take a moment and so to a certain
extent it is you're going to feel fear
you know this emotion will arise at you
like a sneeze you're not choosing it
just kind of comes and when it comes you
need to experience it and let it pass
what if it doesn't go away when you let
it pass though what I mean because
there's there are a lot of people who
have you can call it fearful habits
they've been worrying about something
for a long time like you know let's use
getting sick there but there are people
who are you know not necessarily
obsessive about it
but it's you know it's in the back of
their mind say they're you know immune
compromised or they've had a lot of
sickness and they're family or they know
that the people around them aren't
washing their hands like you'd want the
right people around them or coughing so
they they you know they confront their
fear they look at it and you know allow
it to pass over them and then they look
behind it and it's still there what do
they do that lets see we should try to
reevaluate why we're fearing in the
first place I guess to take a little bit
of a moment of mindfulness and try to
maybe examine the way that our mind is
processing at the moment yeah you have a
different idea well I was thinking that
that's good and then you know like
analyzing you know okay what am I
actually afraid of here and maybe
talking it out with somebody can help
sometimes but what if I mean what if we
were to say okay I'm gonna be afraid
that that's where I am right now maybe a
year from now in a similar situation
with working on stuff I won't be but
right now I am yeah and I'm not gonna
like drastically change that in the next
two weeks that I'm supposed to be you
know self isolating or something like
that
while we're figuring out what's what's
going on with this this this virus and
and all the containment efforts and
stuff like that I mean you can still do
the right thing for yourself and for
others while you're feeling fear it
requires a choice
- while you're feeling it not allow it -
to run the show right right and so it
could be okay that ideally it's better
if you're not afraid all the time of
something that you don't need to be
afraid of or not afraid to the to the
same level right guess this returns back
to Socrates charioteer where's that
Plato
well it's Plato so how do you how do you
see that figuring in the Phaedrus
metaphor yes the the charity here is the
the one that is on reining in our
desires both negative and positive
oh yeah yeah and you always have the
desires and ragging you around but you
you have a choice of what you do with it
mm-hmm right right okay yeah that makes
sense that's that's actually a good way
to look at it yeah so well the end of
this and I look back well I look back
and there he says there's nothing so
just there's just me and you know
ideally that would that would be what
happens to us mm-hmm
I'm not you know a been together it's
other qualities and in training and yeah
you know when you have other ears and
other dimension to it when you have
other people in your life the way most
of us do you know like I think about my
kids and fortunately it seems like this
virus is not doing too much to kids but
you know I think about what their
schools doing and how they're packed in
there with all these other kids and
turning into little vectors yeah yeah
and and you know you think okay what's
how are the people that I love or care
about or in some way are connected with
how are they going to be rendered
vulnerable to this mm-hmm
I might say well it's not that big of a
deal for me I should actually think it's
a big deal for me you know pushing 50
but maybe I'm less fearful about that
but I might be more fearful for those
I'm can
with mm-hmm or I think about my students
and how disconcerting this must be for
them to be told hey we're moving
everything online and you know some I'm
used to teaching online but I know a lot
of my fellow instructors are not and so
they're anxious about it and I think
their students are anxious about it how
is all this stuff going to work out you
know they're not particularly resilient
I would say and so I I feel you know a
sense of worry about them but you know
how can a the key is to not allow that
to keep me from doing the things that I
need to do like shifting the class
online and being there to provide sort
of a steady you know hand at the helm
for for the class and doing all those
sorts of things well this has been a
lovely conversation our discussion and
but we do have a question well the
question is going to be basing further
along in this conversation and so the
the question stems from worries about
the the current virus it says I'm
worried about the new coronavirus they
say it's a pandemic and that up to 70%
of the world's population may eventually
get it there's already cases here in my
home state I don't want to get sick or
have my family gets sick how can I stay
safe and you know a lot of the answer to
that is provided in those those things
that we were talking about earlier the
reliable information sites right mm-hmm
how can I stay safe that's not something
that I think we need to answer but the I
don't want to get sick or have my family
gets sick and the you know the idea
about there being 70% you know these
projections that 70% of us are gonna get
it it's not saying 70 percent of us are
gonna die or 70 percent of us are gonna
get really really sick that's that's a
projection about you know the population
and in a very broad sense right and so
we we want to when we hear those figures
or when we were looking at the current
figures and they're like there's more
cases in France there's more case
in Iran there's more cases in even
Seattle we don't want to allow those
things to get blown out of proportion in
our minds and it's very easy for that to
happen right right so that's something
we want to be on guard against I think
mm-hmm
to let our minds take us to a place
where is not useful information and it's
not useful state to be in right yeah and
that and that's another thing that we
can use as a criterion so the usefulness
right you know the the there's a quote
from the the poem if by Rudyard Kipling
if you can keep your head when all about
you are losing theirs if you can meet
triumph and disaster and treat those two
Impostors just the same so this is and a
little bit of stiff upper upper lifting
it up er lip yes yeah but it is you know
it is useful that there is a thing that
is almost Titanic in nature that is
bearing down upon us and it can be a
little bit overwhelming but there is a
need a bit of a courage maybe we can go
into Aristotle here and the golden mean
about what is required of us in the
moment and a regardless of the odds and
the the chances are out there to do the
right thing to come about this in a just
manner so if we're gonna go - yes dawdle
we have this idea the golden mean and
what is to be courageous and he puts on
a spectrum between that person who
cowers while all the rest of the city
are out fighting and defending it from
innovator of versus that one guy who who
runs out away from the group and right
into a group of you know maybe 400 enemy
soldiers the sake of glory or yeah and
and so that that's recklessness
and and that that golden mean of sitting
there and doing what you need to do but
don't just throw it all away yeah you
know there's there is a cognitive
component to Aristotle's discussion of
courage as well he talks about the
courageous person does fear but they
they fear you know things that it makes
sense to fear so the things that that
people naturally find quite fear
inducing like you know if it tornadoes
bearing down in you it makes perfect
sense to be filled with fear but you
could still actually like get the the
children into the cinderblock area or
they're likely to survive or something
like that
even though you're filled with fear you
don't allow it to paralyze you this kind
of brings up our last week's pre-med at
how to malorum ways to deal with fear
there's going to be fearful situations
in your life and if you have already
thought about what those types of things
could be and have thought of at least
some plans how you should be dealing
with those reactions and allows you to
more easily find a solution to that
fearful situation yeah last week we
talked about it so we use the term
pramana Tatsuo malorum which is Latin
term meaning sort of thinking ahead
about bad things that could happen and
last week we call that negative
visualization and so you know those are
essentially you know interchangeable and
what do you do well you can do it ahead
of time but we can also do it in a
crisis that we're in and we can think
about so let's say we we start you start
coughing right anyway no it's a it's a
dry cough and oh I feel like I've got a
fever and now you start feeling as you
know a sense of fear growing within you
maybe even a sense of panic or a sense
of serious anxiety you can say to
yourself okay what is the worst-case
scenario I get really really sick I'm
gonna die they're not going to have a
respirator for me because it's
taken somewhere else and all that and
then you can think yourself okay what
what's gonna happen because of that
right it's in a way it's sort of like
thinking about cause and effect beyond
just the thing that tends to hold our
attention and captivate us we place it
in another context and you know odds are
you probably not gonna die right and
okay you might get really sick and maybe
you're gonna lose your job and because
of that you're not going to be able to
pay the rent for that month and that's
pretty bad right yeah but it's not the
end of the world and it is remedy Bowl
and there probably are some things you
can appeal to or find some some
resources kind of comes to another quote
that I have oh good for this one which
is it is not the things that disturb men
oh yeah but their judgments about them
for example death is nothing
catastrophic or else Socrates too would
have thought so rather the judgment that
death is Cass tropic this is the
catastrophic thing so this is by
Epictetus yeah and that's that's that
saying I mean you could say well what
would Socrates say I sort of like the
WWJD thing right but you could do that
with all sorts of others what would
Marcus Aurelius say or what would
Aristotle say and it there's the sort of
like well the Great Sage tells us that
part to it but there's also the fact
that hey if they could do it we could do
it there's nothing absolutely necessary
about us reacting in the way that we do
even though we tell ourselves oh I have
to be fearful all right not just fearful
I have to be fearful in this way and
then do these actions like going out and
getting as much toilet paper as possible
and not allowing there to be toilet
paper for others yeah we don't want to
fall into the fallacy of authority here
yeah making this decision but definitely
if you look at it as a road map but
these people have been able to do it and
be calm and wise about it then it allows
us to we that are there's precedent
that's a good way to put it
they're almost like what we call path
finders yeah you're right
the they forge a
Road that we can then travel on
ourselves if we choose to and that's
part of it we have to actually choose to
do things that way oh I just wanted to
say because I did bring up the fallacy
from Authority Oh a fallacy from
authority is a logical fallacy doesn't
mean that the argue the conclusion is
incorrect but the way that you get to of
the conclusion is incorrect and the
incorrect concluded or the way that's
incorrect is that just because someone
in authority says something does not
mean that that is the correct thing
right yeah that's a good way to describe
it and you know it doesn't mean that we
have to reject all authority that's
right yeah we don't want to say like oh
you know all the medical professionals
say that we should wash our hands and
like know that I don't care about those
authority I'll not wash my hands we
should yeah we don't have to prove it to
yourself entirely there's some there's
some things that we can take on trust
and should take on trust
you know actually that's another thing
where we could bring up that patinas as
well he you know the Stoics are known
for like establishing what the the thing
they're gonna do is and then sticking
with it right and right persevering and
there's that there's a thing in
Epictetus discourses where he's
confronted with a guy who has decided to
starve himself to death and epictetus
goes up to me says what's wrong with you
and the guy is like hey I made a
decision I'm sticking with it and
epictetus says listen you dummy
that's not stoicism that you know just
just sticking with a stupid decision
that's not actually the thing to do you
have to have a good rational decision
and then you stick with it it's not you
know he calls it just stubbornness or
obstinate seasonings often translated
Aristotle actually has a discussion of
that too and the nikah mckay and ethics
when he's talking about people who
follow through on things that they've
decided to do and following through is
generally good but not if you pick
something stupid to follow throughout
then they you're actually better off
being what he what he calls a Craddock
or you know having weakness of will so
this is gonna be time for our practice
here yeah yeah so our practice this week
is taking a pause otherwise known as
bracketing or if okay yeah an ancient
Greek epic a literally pulling yourself
back from something and it's it's a you
know it's something that you find
running throughout not just early
Western philosophy and also medieval and
modern philosophy it's also found in a
lot of non-western philosophical and
religious traditions as well think about
you know the role it plays in Buddhism
right well right and it's called by a
lot of different names but the basic
idea is that instead of reacting
immediately and automatically to things
you pause and you you you give yourself
a moment and you say are things actually
the way that they appear to me or not
and a lot of people don't like to do
this because they they want to you know
they want to react right away and well a
lot of people don't even know that you
can do it that's true yeah and it's
liberating to be able to do this because
it means that you don't have to be
driven by what you know what what the
ancient Greeks would call appearances or
impressions things that impinge upon us
we often do react to things in a kind of
automatic way and I'll give an example
so you know I'm looking at Twitter and I
see somebody criticizing something that
I like or you know praising something
that I don't like and I are you know and
I you know I think I wish it had a
dislike button so I could push that you
know 20 times
okay well that's that's probably a
stupid reaction that's not gonna that's
actually not particularly helpful more
rational and you know if I if I take a
pause I can do a lot of different things
within that pause but one thing I'm not
doing is automatically thinking or
choosing or doing or saying something
and then in that pause you know there's
a lot of options I can analyze why I'm
feeling the way I'm feeling I can remind
myself of something that I resolve to do
differently
you know there's a lot of options you
could say I I find this really
interesting especially there's the I
don't know if you called a meme shorts
meme on of the my my emotions are valid
which is totally like a correct
statement but okay take the next step
yes you on my emotions are valid so I
don't need to analyze my emotions and
I'm just going to follow where they go
on I think is a poor next decision there
yeah and it is a decision right and
people conceal from themselves the fact
that they they are choosing it that
they're responsible for it so who can do
this practice well anybody can but like
you were saying a lot of people don't
realize that they can it's not it's not
easy to do in every situation although
the more you practice it the better you
get at it right yeah so so what is the
the best reason why to do this so
short-term what you're doing is keeping
yourself out of various types of trouble
and it could be like actually like
keeping yourself from getting arrested
right you know ruining a relationship
gives the cop me yeah yeah exactly
or flip them off you know yeah that's
also that'll get you in a lot of trouble
too sometimes depending on who the cop
is what they're feeling that day they
might have an automatic response right
so so short-term it helps to keep us out
of trouble at a very baseline level but
it also offers us the opportunity to
figure out what we're doing and and
longer-term it's it's it's something
that you need to do in order to be able
to do other philosophical or what we
sometimes call spiritual practices if
you don't have the self-control to be
able to just stop and pause and figure
out what what's going on well you can't
do you know other things when you need
to and another part of the the long-term
benefit is like at first it's very
difficult it takes yeah it takes a lot
to say okay stop you know evaluate and
but the more and more that you do it
kind of like you know you're
idea of like you are what you repeatedly
do once you get to the point where this
has become your standard response to
stop and and evaluate yeah this this
allows such a on beautiful way of
interaction with the world instead of
just kind of going along for the ride
yeah it helps you see more of the world
right and it helps you see more of not
just yourself but other people if you
pause then the person who anger might
have led you into automatically writing
off you can actually kind of like see
who they are and where they're coming
from and maybe be empathetic to them you
might still say well they're still wrong
and I need to you know avoid them or
something like that but now you have a
good reason to do it you're not just
simply responding yeah and and so when
is this practice useful ideally all the
time right although you wouldn't want to
just be like doing you know every single
thing you automatically bracket it
because we have to we have to live a
life right and there are some things
where you probably do want to like throw
yourself in right mm-hmm and and go
along with the flow if you're you know
romantically and tangled with somebody
and the throws of passion I don't think
you need to like pause and say what am I
feeling right here at the moment well it
kind of depends are you already in a
relationship with someone else do they
know about this other relationship that
you're starting those are other factors
oh I'm in the throes of passion maybe I
should stop for a moment and consider
reconsider I think if those are the
sorts of questions that are occurring to
you you brought yeah you're probably
right
all right you probably also had a couple
other moments that you should have been
evaluating earlier but yeah I mean it's
something that when we get into so like
situations that we're in now like we're
in this big messy pandemic situation
that is causing a lot of fear and
anxiety for people and when they start
feeling overcome by that they can take
that pause they can say okay I don't
have to react to my fear I can just like
feel the fear and like take a look at it
and see what's what's you know
triggering this for me and
how much fear I'm feeling at this time
and then it could also be good for you
might so that's like as might you'd call
it a chronic thing that we could talk
about it like acute instances right
where something happens and like so
let's say you're sitting next to
somebody on the bus and suddenly they're
coughing next to you oh you know I don't
know maybe maybe it's useful then mom
you could say something that's happening
in a lot of workplaces anybody coughs
anybody sneezes everybody's worried
right right so maybe you take a pause
any and you remind yourself okay odds
are there they have allergies or music
or with something else so that that
could be helpful and you could also do
it as a practice with things that are
much more low stakes
yeah like watching TV you can go and
watch you know your your choice of
24-hour news networks and listen to the
top of my head yeah that could actually
be a good practice because they're
guaranteed to say something that you
will react to right so practice on
someone that you don't actually are
actively interacting with yeah and you
can you could actually do that in the
places where you're stuck watching TV
and like the doctor's office all right
where somebody's got it cranked up real
high and it's some you know daytime show
yeah well it looks like it's time to
start thinking about wrapping up so what
what any any last thoughts fear is a
hell of a drug uh how so that's an
interesting when I go out on yeah just
that on in in the idea that a drug
changes one's perspective on the world
okay a lot of times you know your your
perception has been altered to a certain
extent yeah and and especially when
there's mass fear that it results in
really outsized actions and people can
become kind of addicted to it you could
say alright okay and I'm going we're
guys have a good day bye
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]